لا شك ان المشهد الانتخابيه التركي كان
محطه انظار عالميه مشاركه بلغت تسعه
وثمانين في المئه لبلد يناهز عدد سكانها
90 مليونا مشهد لم تتوقعه ربما العواصم
الغربيه او خيبت النتائج امل رغم ذلك من
المانيا الى امريكا مرورا بفرنسا وعلى غير
العاده لم تتاخر هذه المره تهنئه الزعماء
لاردوغان مؤخرا السياسه الاوروبيه مع عده
دول تختلف معها في التوجهات مثل المجار
والهند والبرازيل باتت مختلفه توقفت
اوروبا عن الانتقادات وعملت على المصلحه
المشتركه السياسه الغربيه مع هذه الدول
تهدف لمنع المد الروسي وتقسيم العالم
الجديد الى معسكر شرقي وغربي تركيا ايضا
تندرج ضمن هذه الفئه بالنسبه للغرب فهي
مثلا تلعب دور الوسيط مع روسيا بشان
السلام مع اوكرانيا وب شان اتفاقيه تصدير
الحبوب لكن هناك في الدول الغربيه من يغرد
خارج الصربه
[موسيقى]
بمجرد مغادره بريطانيا للاتحاد الاوروبي
تحولت الى لاعب حر داخل الناتو يبحث عن
مصالحه حتى وان تعارضت مع حليفته
التاريخيه واشنطن اقصاء امريكا لتركيا من
برنامج مقاتله الجيل الخامس 35 بسبب
شرائها لنظام اس اربع مئه الروسي ضربه
موجعه لانقره التي تسعى لتعويض مقاتلات اف
16 المتقدمه الا ان مساعده من لندن طلبت
الازمه الى مشروع قومي تركيا اعلنت نيتها
تطوير مقاتله تي اف اكس من الجيل الخامس
والتصميم وصف بانه نسخه من افخم 35 لكن
ماذا عن المعدات شركه
البريطانيه التي صممت مقاتله تايكون
الاوروبيه قررت التكفل بالتصميم ومرافقه
المشروع التركي في صفقه قدرت من 125 مليون
دولار وفي الوقت نفسه شركه رولز رويس
البريطانيه الرائده في صناعه محركات
الطائرات تعلن انها مستعده لتصنيع ونقل
تكنولوجيا محركات المقاتله التركيه مقاتله
تي اف اكس لن تطير قبل عام 2030 لكنها
ربحت وقتا طويلا خاصه وان المصنع الذي كان
موجها لصناعه هيكل اف 35
سيتحول لصناعه هيكل المقاتله التركيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات